let's stay in the nfc the rams have
placed receiver cooper cup on the covet
19 reserve list unclear whether that's a
positive which would knock him out for
this weekend's game or or a close
contact and the thing about close
contact you never quite know when the
guy pops off because it's five days
after exposure and negative testing and
eventually you can come back we'll see
if cooper cup is available the most
important thing for the los angeles rams
at this point who missed the playoffs
last year after going to super bowl 53
know jared goff this weekend as they
play the arizona cardinals in what very
well will be an elimination game
depending upon what happens with the
bears and uh the rams uh you know they
need all the help they can get if
they're not going to have jared goff
it's john wolford at quarterback with
blake bortles backing him up daryl
henderson one of the top running backs
on ninja reserve they need cam akers
back not having cam acres this past
weekend against the seahawks hurt them
they are in with a win or a bears loss
to the packers and that quite possibly
will happen it may be the rams don't
need this game and maybe they back into
the playoffs with john wolford playing
quarterback in his first nfl regular
season game
um we'll see how good of a coach sean
mcvey is this weekend if he can whip up
some chicken salad out of john walford
shereen
you know what i forgot mike and somebody
brought this up on social media and i
went and reread that season but the 1979
ram season and i don't know if you
remember this john
hayden broke his pinky pat hayden broke
his pinky finger and vince ferragamo
ended up coming in and the team was five
and six at that point and under vince
ferragamo who had never played in the
nfl uh at all had never taken a snap
leads them to the super bowl and they
almost won the super bowl over the
steelers that season so can john wolford
recreate what vince ferragama did in
1979 i have doubts that that'll happen
but we'll see it's just a little bit
past history that you and i both
remember uh at least that season if not
that exact thing that happened
31-19 was the final score of that game
it was the long pass from terry bradshaw
to john stalworth just over the
outstretched hands of a defensive back
i've got the sports illustrated with
that photo on the cover as the ball tear
drops into john stallworth's fingers and
that was the moment when
well it still wasn't over but that was
the moment when steelers fans could
exhale at this unexpected threat they
got from the rams and fast forward 20
years from that to kurt warner although
it happened at the beginning of the
season not the end shireen you know the
rams had some buzz with marshall falk
and they signed trent green from
washington as a free agent our friend
rodney harrison hit trent green low in
the preseason blew out his acl it's like
okay
scratch the rams off the list this year
and comes this this guy who played in
the arena league and the world league
and he used to bag groceries and
nobody's ever heard of kurt warner well
i heard a kurt warner is a running back
for the seahawks actually from pineville
west virginia no not that kurt warner a
different kurt warner he spells his
first name different and the next thing
you know he's the last guy to be regular
season mvp and super bowl mvp so maybe
john walford becomes the next success
story and and hey i said it yesterday if
you're going to give jared goff or sean
mcvay 33.5 million per year you give it
to mcvay this is the chance for mcveigh
to show that he's the one that should be
getting the 33 and a half million in l.a
not jared goff
yeah and and uh
sean mcveigh will get that chance this
week mike because he has a tough task
and as you said probably won't get half
cam acres because of the high ankle
sprain daryl henderson high ankle sprain
that leaves two rookies behind malcolm
brown who's going to be the running back
so john wolford's not going to have a
lot of help especially if he doesn't
have cooper cup in the lineup this is a
tall tall task not only for john wilfer
but for sean mcvay to try to draw up
some plays that that'll work uh this
week and get them in the playoffs and if
they get there who knows how they'll do
i have doubts that they'll last very
long if they do get in there but i know
they'd like to get in there and
especially the way they've lost over the
last two weeks they should already be in
the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports